yo what's up guys marcus brownlee here
from mkbhd and i have another software
video for you guys this one you've been
asking for on twitter i was actually uh
you know hinting at this video on
twitter uh but uh this is actually a
video about how to download and install
google uh google chrome 2.0 actually
kind of an announcement video uh letting
you guys know 2.0 is out and i'm just
going to show you number one how to
update it if you already have it and
number two how to just install it so the
first thing i'm going to show you is how
to install it so just go ahead and
search google
google chrome in any major search engine
or anything like that and the first link
should be google.com chrome that's the
one you're going to want to use and
we're going to go ahead and download and
install
and we're going to accept and install
google chrome it's very simple
installation
this is basically a video telling you
guys that you can get google chrome now
and the download and everything for
google chrome is obviously very simple
very quick and um just lets you get the
the the latest version of this web
browser
so i'm going to actually pause the video
if it's not done already oh it is done
already so um google chrome has finished
downloading installing and everything
just like that so let's exit out of
safari so we have google chrome open
already here
and um
basically if you already have google
chrome then the way to update it would
be to go actually i believe to this uh
this wrench tool on the right hand side
and go to the about google chrome button
and it'll say either google chrome is up
to date or it'll tell you that you have
a version one point something and you're
going to want to hit the update now
button and hit ok to make sure you have
the latest version and that is how to
get the latest version of google chrome
obviously there's not much else to tell
you guys about google chrome other than
it is probably the fastest web browser
out there right now it has um
you know obviously autocomplete and all
that if you already had google chrome uh
it'll be up there it'll still work uh so
basically that is it for this video just
letting you guys know google chrome 2.0
is out the final version it is finally
out of beta and i might actually
consider using this web browser now i've
been using safari for a little while
just to avoid using a beta web browser
like google chrome even though safari 4
is in beta
so anyway thanks for watching this hd
tutorial i hope it was helpful just a
quick software video if you didn't
already know and enjoy google chrome
guys thanks for watching peace